hi
everyone welcome to this video on python
projects by simply learn
today we will learn three hands-on
projects that will help you improve your
python coding skills
we have with us anish karan who will
take us through these projects
so the first project we are going to see
is given a block of text
you will count the frequency of each
word occurring in the text or paragraph
in the second project you will trace the
movement of a robot
the robot can move up down left or right
you will write a program to find the
distance between the starting point
after a sequence of movements in the
final project
we will write a program to check the
validity of passwords given by the user
often by logging into a website or an
application
you are asked to input the username and
password to register
our project will check the criterias for
setting a password and approve it only
when the criterias are met
so a password should have at least one
letter between a to z
at least one number between 0 to 9 one
uppercase letter
one special character and so on so let's
get started with our first project
hello everyone and welcome to another
video on python programming
in this video we will be covering a sort
of a project site type of scenario
which is basically going to be a problem
case for you
and it's going to be slightly slightly
difficult slightly tricky
um but what we're going to do is we're
going to tackle a particular problem
and we're going to what i'm going to do
is also
show you a solution to that problem so
let's start with this so this question
that we have is
um we have this program that we have to
write where we compute the frequency of
words that exist in some input
okay the program should output after
sorting the key alpha numerically
now this input can be any it's basically
a block of text right
so in our example we have for example
if this was our input right uh what we
want to see is
um an output which is basically saying
that uh the word python
has appeared say well in this example
it's appeared five times
and then the word read has appeared one
time and so on and so forth like for
each of these words
we want to see how many times have they
appeared in this
particular block of text so let's look
at
a particular example now where we have
done this
so let's um let's see here so first of
all i'm going to create a dictionary
so why am i creating a dictionary is
because i'm going to use each
unique word as a key and the number of
times they have appeared in
a block of text as the value to that key
so
i'm going to use a sample string which
is
basically this long string that you can
see here which is stored in line
so this large chunk of text is what
we're going to be analyzing
um so how are we going to do this it's
pretty simple
so we have this now what we want to do
is um when we find what we one way of
tackling this problem that we're going
to do here
is we want to um check
word by word um first of all we want to
see if it's a unique word and if this
word is
um before i encountered it for the first
time then we need to store a new key
in our dictionary called frequent table
or frequency table
um and if it has already if there is a
key already with that
particular name then we just want to
increment the count or the value by one
so let's see how we do this over here so
if you can see in my this
the solution is as simple as this but if
you see what's happening
it's basically what uh what it's doing
is we're splitting up
this string uh using the split function
what this will do
is it will split up the string at every
white space
so it will take this as one part and
take this part as another part it will
create an
iterable with each word as the
um each iterable object in that
container so it's going to be a list of
words like python is one so on and so
forth
and we're going to go one by one so
we're going to say forward in
line dot split now if this word is
if it exists in frequency table as a key
then
what we're going to do is we're just
going to increase the count
of the value of that key by one but if
it does not exist then we're going to
actually create
a key with the word as that unique word
and we're going to
create its value initialize its value to
one
so when we execute this now
if we want to once you've done this we
can sort it
by the count of the words so what we're
going to do is we're going to create
a another tuple called sorted tuples
where we're going to use the lambda
function out here
to sort the
the dictionary in terms of its values
so what we're going to do is we're going
to take the key
uh the key being the lambda item item
with index one index one is basically
the value
um so a particular key has a value
so the word python appears so many times
the per the word
say scientist appears so many times so
we're going to check which
words have the highest number of
occurrences and we're going to sort it
in a
descending order so that that is
basically what the reverse is equal to
true does
so when we're going to sort this when
we're going to use the sorted function
when we say reverse true it tells the
sorting function to sort
this dictionary this dictionary
frequency table
in terms of value by the the descending
order
so whichever um word appears highest
that would be the first word in our
sorted tuple so that's what we do in
this line and once we execute this we're
also going to print
so if you see the result of this
activity that we've done you can see
that the word
machine um appears six times
learning appears six times then python
appears 510 and so on and so forth
so we've created a sorted tuple where
the first object will be tuple we've
created a list of
sorted tuples where the first object of
the tube each tuple is the
unique word and then the second one is
the number of times that
it has appeared in this um particular
example or this particular string so
yeah this was
the first basic project that we have
tackled if getting your learning started
is half the battle
what if you could do that for free visit
scale up by simply learn
click on the link in the description to
know more
hello everyone and welcome to another
video on python programming
in this video we will continue with what
we started in terms of our
project number one what we're going to
do is um we're going to tackle another
slightly complicated
a question or a situation we're going to
try to arrive at a solution
so in this what we have is some sort of
a robot a moving robot
which moves on a cartesian plane a two
coordinate plane
um is going to move in terms of up down
left and right
okay and each each time it moves up or
down or left or right it takes a certain
number of steps in that direction
integral steps of course so what we need
to do is
from a starting position whatever its
starting position is which we are going
to take as 0
comma 0 in this example we are going to
make it move to
a particular location with the commands
up down left and right followed by
certain steps um and we're going to
ask what we're going to do is we're
going to calculate the distance between
these two points
um and we're going to calculate
different types of distances so you
might be introduced to new concepts
um your distance concepts in this video
as well
so what we're going to be using for
distance calculation is the minkowski
distance
and that is um we're going to take
so the minkowski distance between two
variables is basically
the absolute difference between these
two uh variables at these two points
um and we take it to the power of
something so if we want to say
uh calculate the minkowski distance with
um
in terms of the quadratic main cause
distance with basically p2
so we are going to do x i minus y i
absolute difference to the power 2
and then we're going to take the second
root of it after summing each and every
point um
so when we take p is equal to two we we
say the minkowski distance behaves like
the euclidean distance and this is
probably one of the most common
distances
uh in case you've done basic
cartesian geometry when you are asked to
find the distance between two points on
a plane
um we can also take the absolute
distance where we take p is equal to one
so in this case we're just basically
summing the absolute distances between
each point
um no roots no powers nothing basically
p is equal to one and we call that the
manhattan distance
so we're going to take p is equal to one
two and three in each case
and we're going to find the distance
between two points uh based on these
measures so this is just a visual
representation this is basically the
euclidean
distance basically the estimate of the
value between these two points
if um since this is a two coordinate
system whereas the manhattan distance
would be
the absolute distance in terms of um if
we go
up and then we go right between these
two like save this first and this was
another point
um so yeah let's uh move on to the
problem
so what in this in this particular
example we are going to start from the
starting position 0 and 0 on a
on a graph and we are going to give the
commands of up 5
down 3 left 3 and right 2. so first of
all what we want to do is
um we initialize the starting position
as 0 and 0
and we also just for the sake of this
example we initialize the end position
as 0 and 0.
so what we're going to do first of all
is
let's execute this much now we have this
list
list of tuples um it's we're going to
call this actions and this is the
actions that we're performing
so the this the each tuple contains an
action
and the number of steps in that
direction so it contains four actions
up by five steps down by three steps
left by three
steps right by two steps so now we're
going to iterate over this each tuple
and we're going to get the direction
first of all in this line
um for each step uh and we're going to
calculate the number of steps it takes
so for each action it's going to first
tell um it's going to check what is the
direction which is done by
this line and we're going to find out
the number of steps in that direction
which is
stored in this line so once you've
gotten this for each action we have to
uh update the end position right
so what happens is if you go up by
a particular direction so you are
basically changing the y
y axis right the uh the y-axis so we're
going to change
end position and the first index which
is basically
this part of the end position
coordinate point so we're going to say
if it's moving by up
then we're going to uh update by adding
uh the y-axis by the number of steps
so um and and if the direction was down
we're going to do the same thing for the
y-axis but we're going to decrement it
similarly if we move left or right we're
moving the x-axis right
so we take n position in the first index
so we take the x-axis and if you're
moving left
it's a negative uh it's a decrement and
if you're moving right it's an increment
so if there's any other like action
like any other action for example that
was given here
we say pass so basically the only valid
actions that we can pass is um up down
left and right
otherwise we we just skip that
particular action
so this is what the this particular loop
will do it will update our final
position so once we've done this
um if we if i execute this what will get
stored in the end position is basically
my end position
so now that i have my starting position
and my end position
um just to show you what the end
position will look like right now
let's just do this so if you see here
after i've moved up by five steps down
by three steps left by three steps and
then right by two steps
my final end position is minus one and
two
my start position on the other hand
was as you remember
it should be 0 and 0. it is 0 and 0.
so now we're going to find the distance
between 0 and 0 and minus 1 and 2.
so we're going to first of all create a
function called minkowski distance
which which does the basic function of
just calculate the
uh the difference between the
what do you say um the end position x
coordinate and the n position y
coordinate
times uh or to the power of a root
and uh we're basically going to do this
operation that
you saw here we're going to do this and
um
we're going to uh we're going to
use this root variable to specify
to like p is equal to 1 2 or 3 like what
p value we want to take for this
minkowski distance
so once we've done this what this
function will do is basically store
uh this much and it will wait for us to
uh
it will basically wait for us to give us
a route so when we give root one
it will create these it will check the
distance between the end and the
starting points
um with the p value of one if we give it
two it will calculate euclidean distance
with p value two
similarly for three and we can calculate
for any roots so we're going to
calculate for one two and three roots
um and we're going to see what values we
get in each case
so when root is equal to 1 i print a
statement saying minkowski distance with
root 1
is something and then root 2 is
something root 3 something let's see
what results we get
so if you see here the minkowski
distance with root 1 is actually
1.0 but the euclidean distance between
these two points is 2.23
whereas the um the cubic minkowski
distance
with basically the with root 3 is 1.91
so you see these three different uh
distance measures for the same distance
between two points
so in this video you basically so in
this basically by doing this activity
you might must have
you will learn how to um basically how
to
iterate through loops um and perform
these
distance calculations which you'll find
pretty handy in
many activities related to data science
and machine learning
so yeah this was on the project too
hello everyone and welcome to another
video on python programming
in this video we will be continuing
tackling different
problems and problem cases in terms of
a project called project 3 where we're
going to be using regular expressions
to validate whether certain passwords
that have been entered
or do they match certain criterias or
not
so let's look into our particular
question
we have a website that requires users to
input username and password to register
now we have to write a program to check
the validity of passwords input by the
users
now the criterias that the passwords
have to follow are that there's at least
one number between a
and z and this is at least one number
between is at least one letter between a
and z and one number between zero and
nine
uh the third criteria is that uh there's
at least one letter between capital a
and capital z so this first and third
point basically is saying
that there should be one lowercase
letter and there should be one uppercase
letter
um now there should be at least one
character from dollar sign
or the at simple um it should have a
minimum length
of 6 and the maximum length of 12.
so when we whatever passwords that we
enter into our
example they must be commas separated so
if we're going to have an input
they're going to ask us for an input
where we're going to have to input the
different passwords
in a comma separated way so let's look
let's look at
how do we tackle this so for my example
i'm going to use these
uh examples in terms of these are my
password examples if we're going to
check
if these are valid passwords or not so
let's copy this first of all
and now let's import the re this import
rd is basically the regular expression
module
now in this step is going to ask us to
input the passwords
as you can see here so i will just
control v so
since this is comma separated what it
will do is it will split up each of
these
by the comma and it will store them in a
list so it will take this as one
password
this has another password this has
another password
and this has another password once i
press enter
now if i want to check what's in list i
mean what's in items
what i can do is just check over here
what's in items
it's a list of whatever passwords i had
entered each object is separately
treated now
in this list now i'm going to create a
an empty list called value for store
once i've done that i'm going to move on
to the next step
so once i've created my list called
value
what i'm going to do is now i'm going to
search and i'm going to check for each
condition using regular expressions
for whatever criteria that we have
initially
so if you see here what i'm going to do
is first iterate by each item in this to
check for each password
now my first check will be a basic check
for the length of the password
if it's lesser than 6 or greater than 12
then
our um our basically our password
is illegal so we can't be using this and
we will just continue
and we won't check for anything else but
if it is within 6 and 12 the length
uh 6 and 12 then we can continue
with our check so we can do we'll do an
statement for pass which basically moves
on to this
next block now once we've done this
what we will do is this this first
statement what this is going to do is
it's going to do an re dot search an rdd
search as you know
is going to look for at least one
instance of
a letter occurring between a and z so
this
ire.search followed by this now this is
the regular expression that we
have passed and what this tells us is
basically the square in the square
brackets
we're looking for anything between a and
z
in terms of small letters so if
um this is if this condition is not met
then again we continue
and we leave this particular search
because one of our criterias is not met
all right but if it is met then this if
not statement will not uh
like we won't enter this block and we
can move on to the next check
so now now we move to lf not now again
we're using if not statement so this is
basically checking for
a negative case so any time one of these
cases have been met
it basically means that our password has
been invalid because these conditions
are not being met
so we're trying to eliminate all
conditions all of these conditions so
that we get a valid password
so again we move on to the next
statement which is basically going to do
the
search for numbers once again if we find
a case
a password without any numbers we
continue and we
don't um check this password no more
because we already know it's a
it's a an illegal password now next
check will be for capital letters a to z
um and the next check again will be for
uh these particular symbols the dollar
the hash and the at one of these three
symbols finally we have
a a search for um we're going to search
for a white space character
so if we actually do find a white space
character in our password
um that's an illegal password and we're
not going to continue
checking for those cases so um so this
is basically all our cases
lower case letters numbers capital
letters
these one of these three symbols and the
existence of
a white space so once we've done all
these checks
if if none of these have been passed we
move on to this else statement where we
just pass
and uh what we can do is we append the
value
we append the value to uh we we append p
to the
uh the i the list called value so
basically what happens is um just to go
through it again
um if this condition is not met uh
and this condition is not met this is
not met this is not met this is not met
and if this is
also not met um then we're fine so
basically as long as we have small
letters
as long as we have a number as long as
we have a capital letter
as long as we have one of these three
symbols and as long as we don't have
any uh white space characters we can
append
e to this otherwise it will continue and
it will break out of this for loop
completely that's what the continue
thing
the continue statement at the end of
each of these blocks
checks um anytime this condition is met
this if not condition is met then we
break through we break
through this uh whole for loop and we
don't append p to the value
but uh if we actually get to this stage
then what we can do is simply append
uh p to value now finally
what we are going to do is uh we are
going to print out all the valid
um all the valid passwords so just by a
quick look
you can see here um this is
a valid password right so let's execute
this and let's see
uh what we get if you see here we only
get one valid password
and let's look at why um some of these
did not turn out to be valid
so if you look here all of the
conditions are met it has a capital
letter it has a small letter it has at
least one number
and it has one of the symbols either
dollar sign or the hash sign or the add
sign
in this case we have two white spaces
one over here and one over here
so this is an illegal password similarly
in this case
also we have an illegal password because
it begins with a space
in this case it's the same thing we
begin with a space and also
it does not have any of those symbols
that we were looking for
the dollar or the hash or the at so
again so these three are illegal
passwords and they do not get appended
to value
however this does get appended to value
and that's why we get the result for
only one password which is the only
legal password
thank you all for watching this video
tutorial on python projects
i hope you liked it please make sure to
subscribe to the simply learn channel
and hit the bell icon to stay updated
with all the latest trending
technologies
stay tuned for more from simply learn
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified click here